GERBRAND CEDER: What
we're going to do
is work through
several case studies
so you'll see it get
more and more applied.
I'll start with doing a
little more of alloy theory
and cluster expansions,
which is really
a follow up on the
Monte Carlo work
we did and you'll see how that
fits in with course grading.
It's essentially the part we
didn't get to when I finished.
And then I'll do a variety
of things on Tuesday.
One of them is [INAUDIBLE]
accelerated molecular dynamics
technique, which is sort
of a specialty topic
but it gives you an
idea of where people are
trying to push the boundaries.
And then on Thursday, we'll
actually have a guest lecture.
We'll have Chris Wolverton from
Ford Motor Company lecture.
It's kind of cool, he
actually lectures from Ford
so you're going to see
him project on the screen.
He does that every year
and people usually find
that a really good lecture.
He essentially
talks about how they
use modeling in general but in
particular, first principles
methodology at
Ford Motor Company.
He has a few really
cool stories.
He won't tell you how much
money they save the company,
but it's actually in the
tens of millions of dollars
so that's why
they're still there.
He won't tell you that,
but I can tell you
that before his talk show.
That's on Thursday, and then
we go into the last week
and I think we have only
one more lecture left there.
So one of the things
I want to do today
is be a little more systematic
about some of the models we've
introduced for your lab.
We introduced this lattice
model, for example,
to model hydrogen
absorption on palladium
and several people have
questions, you know?
How do you know that
this is a good model?
Those lattice models
actually occur
all the time in a solid
state structure equilibration
thermodynamics and I'll go
through them a little more
systematic today and
then towards the end
prove to you that
they actually are
a very accurate representation
of the thermodynamics
of real systems.
So let me show you again where
they will tend to show up.
I introduced the
lattice model too simply
as a magnetic spin model,
and that's how we started.
You model a magnet and you
have up and down spins.
But as soon as you realize
that those spins are really
just general
occupation variables,
they tell you the result
of a binary outcome,
you can also use
them to represent
a whole lot of other things.
For example, if you
look at superstructures
in the copper-gold system--
copper is FCC, gold is FCC,
all the structures in between
are in an FCC lattice.
So if you really want to know
how they look, the question is,
how do you distribute copper
and gold on an FCC lattice?
So really all you need to
know is on every lattice site,
is there a copper there
or is there a gold?
Again, that's a binary
outcome, so you can represent
that with spin variables.
So essentially the energetics
and thermodynamics of this
will be represented by a spin
model, also by a lattice model.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be atoms,
it can be atoms and vacancies.
This is an example I'll
come back to later,
this is lithium cobalt oxide.
The purple things up there
are lithium, red is oxygen,
and the green is cobalt. You
can actually extract lithium
from these materials,
and so start
removing some of the lithiums.
And so essentially
what you have then
is a distribution problem
of lithiums and vacancies
on a given set of sites.
In this case, those planes
that you're looking head on
are actually triangular
lattices, OK?
And I'll come back
to that as well.
So here the spin variable would
indicate whether the site is
occupied by a lithium or not.
You can do surfaces.
Lattice models are
classics for surfaces.
Here's a typical 111 surface
with stuff absorbed on it.
So if you look at an
FCC metal like platinum
and you look at the 111
surface, the absorption sites
have the same symmetry.
For example, the hollows,
which I've indicated here.
So the hollows form a
triangular lattice, OK?
And so if you look
at absorption,
again, all you need to
know is, is there something
at the absorption site or not?
So again, you would
use a binary variable.
So what I first
want to show you is
that an Ising-like model
or a lattice Hamiltonian,
as you've seen
before, is actually
a very natural way
of writing the energy
and actually, I
extend that later
to any property
of configuration.
So I'm going to do that
a little more formally
than we've done before.
Essentially if you
want to study all
of these models that
are lattice models,
you need some
Hamiltonian for them.
And so I'm going
to use this sigma
between these squiggly
brackets as a variable
to indicate the configuration
on the whole lattice.
So the variable sigma is
essentially a combination
of sigma 1, sigma 2, sigma 3.
So you can think of as a vector
in the configurational space
of all the occupation variables.
So what you need
is a practical way
of writing that
configurational Hamiltonian,
and the way you make
you write almost
any practical Hamiltonian
or any practical energy
function that you want
as accurate as possible
is that you write it as some
expansion in a suitable basis
set of functions.
OK?
Think of how you
explain wave functions
in plane waves,
how you sometimes
expend in sines or cosine.
The typical basis
that's used here
is what's called
cluster functions.
A cluster function, which I'm
going to label by phi alpha,
is essentially the spin
product of all the sites
of that cluster alpha.
So if I make a pair cluster,
let's say this one, i and j,
the cluster function phi alpha
then is sigma i times sigma j.
But I can make many other ones.
I could make a four body
one, they don't even
have to be connected.
And so for the red,
phi alpha would be--
let's call it i, j,
k, l, would be sigma
i, sigma j, sigma k, sigma l.
OK?
I think the computer gets more
tired as well as we proceed.
OK.
The first thing, so when
you expend in a basis,
you want to make sure that the
basis is complete to describe
your full space and
then sometimes it's
useful that your basis
set is orthogonal,
although that's not
really necessary,
but it can be practical.
It's easy to see here
that it's complete.
I mean, if you have
n lattice sites,
what's the size of the space?
What's the size of the
configurational space?
Well, it's 2 to the n.
On each lattice point you can
put two things, essentially,
so the number of
combinations is 2 to the n.
Well, how many basis
functions are there?
Well, if you think of what's
the choice of basis function,
it's essentially picking
a combination of sites.
So that's also 2 to the n.
There are 2 to the n
combinations of sites
because it's also
a binary problem.
For every site, you include
it or you don't include it
in the basis function.
So there are 2 to the
n basis functions.
I'm going to show you in a
second that they're orthogonal.
The basis that is complete,
in a very trivial sense,
there are as many basis
functions as states.
OK?
So you may ask yourself,
what have you won?
We're actually going to expend
things in this basis set,
but there's as many
basic functions as state.
Well, the hope is that we can
formulate these basis functions
so that whatever
quantity we expend
is more rapidly convergent.
So let me prove you that the
basis set is orthogonal if you
take a suitable scalar product.
The way I'm going to define the
scalar product between, say,
any two functions of
configuration, which
I'll call f sigma and g sigma.
OK?
I'm going to define the
scalar product simply
as the sum over the
configuration space
properly normalized.
OK?
So this is equivalent
to if you're
working in a continuous
space defining your scalar
product as the integral
of the product of the two
functions over the
configuration space,
and you might be more
familiar because we have
a discrete configuration space.
That integral is
essentially a sum
over all the possible
configurations.
Let me prove you that the
functions are orthogonal.
First you can note
that for any basis
function, if you sum its value
over the space it gives you 0.
And you can easily see that--
let's say that function
would look something
like sigma i, sigma j, sigma
k, maybe even more terms,
essentially these
terms will alternate
as having plus and minus 1
and so they will sum to 1.
Using that, you can easily
prove that the functions
are orthogonal.
So if you [? adopt ?]
the two basic functions
into each other, so
you're essentially
summing their product, OK?
So let's say we have a cluster
alpha and a cluster beta,
maybe this is the
cluster alpha and maybe
this is the cluster beta.
OK, so they have
a partial overlap.
So you can write the
product of alpha and beta
then as first as the
product of the spins
that are in both alpha and beta.
And for those, you
get sigma i squared,
and then the spins
that are only in alpha
and the spins that
are only in beta.
Of course, sigma i
squared is always one
because sigma is plus or minus
1 your occupation variable
in a spin model, so
essentially this goes away.
OK?
And this is simply a function.
You could write
this as the basis
function of alpha plus theta
minus alpha intersection beta.
OK?
You're essentially
here multiplying
all the spins that are
only in alpha or only
in beta, but not in both.
So that's trivially 0.
So the only time that
this product is not 0
is when this part
doesn't exist, so that
means when all things are
in both alpha and beta.
OK?
So this product is equal
to the Kronecker delta.
It's actually not this
product, I'm sorry.
It's this product summed
over all configuration,
so I should correct this.
It's 1 over 2 to
the n some stigma
and then that should
go in front of here.
So the basis set
is orthogonal, OK?
So we have a very
practical expansion now,
we have a complete and
orthogonal expansion.
So one of the first
things we're going to do
is expend the energy
in this basis set,
because the energy is a
quantity we'll need in things
like Monte Carlo simulation.
But you should right
away see that this
is much more powerful, huh?
You can expend any
property of configuration
in this basis set.
They may have different
rates of conversions,
but essentially
this is a basis set
in which you can expend anything
that depends on how you arrange
the items on a lattice.
So people have done
things like expend
the band gap of materials.
And if that converges
fast, you have
a model that you can
rapidly search then.
People have expended things like
the vibrational entropy in it,
people have expended
things like--
even tried to expend
things like connectivity,
and so which goes not as well.
But essentially
anything that becomes
a property of the arrangement
of atoms on that lattice,
so in that substitution
space can be expended.
For now we're going to
stick to the energy.
So if we expend the energy as
a function of configuration,
so we get an expansion over all
the possible clusters alpha,
the basis function, and then
the expansion coefficient,
which we'll call v alpha, and
so of course the expansion
coefficient that's
going to contain
all the energetic information.
And I'll show you in a
second how it's defined,
but first I want to write out
what this cluster expansion,
as it's called, looks like.
I mean, if you pull out what
these cluster functions are you
essentially get something
that looks like this.
There'll be an empty cluster
function, so that's this term.
When alpha is just a point
you'll have this term.
So this is almost like point
site energies or chemical
potential like.
If alphas are pairs, you'll
get the standard pair term
that we see in lattice models,
but this keeps on going.
You'll have triple terms,
quadruplet terms, and so on.
So essentially the
cluster expansion
is the same as what's
called a generalized Ising
model or "Easing" model, OK?
So where you go away from
relying only on two body terms
to higher body terms as well,
and what it essentially is
is a generalization
of that approach.
I'm sorry, I'm going
back and forth.
I'm interchanging and using e
and h, h for the Hamiltonian,
e for the energy, and
one of the reasons
is that I
cut-and-paste equations
from various PowerPoint
slides and wasn't
quite able to modify them due
to the great Microsoft software.
OK.
But I think what's
the really nice thing
is that this formal expansion
will allow you to define
exactly what these v's are
because you may have asked
yourself when you
were doing in the lab
and are probably still doing
the hydrogen on palladium,
what those interactions
actually are?
Are they sort of
physical potentials
between the hydrogen or not?
You'll see in a second
that they're not,
they're much more
complex than that.
OK.
So whenever you write an
expansion in orthogonal basis
functions, how do you get
the expansion coefficient?
Well, the expansion
coefficient is essentially
the projection of your function
onto the corresponding basis
function, and that's
what you'll see here
and you'll get something
really interesting come out.
So the way to know how
a v alpha is defined,
you can essentially
take the scalar product
of this expression on
both sides with phi beta.
So you multiply with
phi beta and then
some overall configurations.
So you're essentially
taking the scalar product
here, phi beta, phi beta.
On this n, we know that
this is the Kronecker delta,
so this is v beta.
OK?
So we've projected out v
beta out of this expansion,
and then we have to
work out essentially
what this is to know
exactly what v beta means.
And you'll see this is the
projection of the energy
onto the basis
function [? phi a, ?]
but it's interesting
when you work that out
what it physically looks like.
So that's what I'm
going to do here,
so I've written out the
scalar product here.
OK.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going to--
this is the sum over all
possible configurations
of the lattice.
Since I have a basic
function phi beta here,
I'm going to separate that into
a sum over the configurations
on the spins that
belong to beta.
So let's say this is
beta, sum triplet.
So I'm going to sum
over those spins
and then separate that and
sum over all the other spins
on the rest of the lattice.
So I've written that here
as a sum over all the i's--
sorry, this should be sigma i--
that are in beta and summing
over all the configurations,
you get that by just
making all the sigma
i's plus or minus 1, OK?
And then summing over
the configuration space
minus what lives on beta,
and this is a bit shorthand
notation.
It's a little hard to write
formally what you're actually
doing here.
But those of you who are
familiar with quantum mechanics
and so may recognize
this as a reduced trace.
You're essentially tracing over
all of the configuration space
except what lives on beta, OK?
OK, so what I want
to do is work out
the example for pair interaction
since the math is about just
the right level to do in class.
The three body gets
a little harder.
So we're going to work
this out when phi--
sorry, when beta consists
of sites i and j,
so it's a pair interaction.
So you see that
in this first term
I'm going to get four terms
because I have two sides.
I can do a or b, let's say.
Let me call plus 1 is [? ac ?]
and minus 1 is [? b. ?] So
let's say I do the term i
equals plus 1, j equals plus 1.
OK?
So the basis function
is going to be 1
because I have plus
1 times plus 1,
and then what is this really?
Think about this.
So when i and j are plus
1, that means I essentially
decorate this cluster
of sites i and k
with an a atom and an a atom.
So it's an a, a pair.
But what is this term?
Essentially I'm summing over
all the configurations outside
of this cluster, all the spins.
So this is essentially
the average energy
of the configuration
with a, a pairs at i,
j, because look at
what I'm summing over.
So I'm summing it
over the energy of all
the possible
configurations, but it's
configurations that have a fixed
theta occupancy because I'm not
summing over beta.
So this first term
is essentially
what I'll call EAA averaged
So you see what it is?
It's I put a at i,
a at j, and then
I essentially trace over the
remaining configuration space.
So I put all possible
configurations
on the rest of the system and
calculate that average energy.
OK?
So you can do that
for the other terms.
So I'll write out
explicitly now V ij,
because beta is a cluster
consisting of i and j.
We're going to find this n beta
is the number of sites in beta,
so we get 1 over 4 because
the number of sites is 2.
So the first term I got was EAA.
OK.
If I do i equals minus 1 and
j equals minus 1 I'll get,
again, plus 4 phi beta.
So I get plus EBB.
And then if I do i and j a
different spin, so plus 1
and minus 1, I'm going to
get minus EAB minus EBA.
OK?
Does everybody roughly
see where that comes from?
So I essentially
explicitly evaluate
the four terms in that sum
and every time, I essentially
get the average energy
of that configuration.
If your system is symmetric,
if i and j are equivalent,
then these are the same.
OK?
If you have translational
symmetry between i and j,
so then you'll get
something like minus 2EAB.
And those of you who've seen
regular solution thermodynamics
may recognize this very
much as a sort of effective
pre-factor in the
entropy of mixing.
You'll get something like the
AA interaction plus the BB
interaction minus 2
times the AB interaction,
just sort of pointing that out.
But it's sort of
interesting, this
is the formal definition of
the expansion coefficients.
First of all, note that
they are not potentials,
they are energies.
OK?
And they are energies
of configurations.
So this is not the potential
between the a atom at i
and the a atom at j, OK?
The reason is that the
configuration around it
modifies that interaction
substantially, OK?
Typically what you'll find
is that these v's are much,
much smaller than direct
interaction energies,
and the reason is they
contain enormous amount
of cancellation.
If you think about it, this
is AA energy, BB energy,
and minus 2 times the AB energy.
So they're often several
orders of magnitude
smaller than direct interactions
if such a thing were to exist.
The other thing is
that indirect effects
can be included, like if
you truncate your lattice
model at pair terms.
OK?
Because it's an infinite
expansion, at some point
you'll have the truncate it.
You are still including many
body quantum mechanical effects
because the many body quantum
mechanical effects enter
in the calculation of
the energy of these, OK?
So what you should understand
is that the level of physics
or the level at which
you truncate the cluster
expansion, the
lattice Hamiltonian,
has no correspondence to the
level of physics for, say,
your electron physics.
OK?
Let me give you an
example just to think
through what these things are.
Let's say you had a model on
a lattice where things just
interacted with
pair potentials, OK?
So a very simplistic
energetic scheme.
If the atoms don't relax
away from the lattice points,
then these energies can really
be written as a pairwise sum
because then the total
energy of a system
is really the pairwise
sum between all the pairs.
Then now what
you're going to find
is that essentially,
all of the pairwise sum
cancels in this
difference except the AA
interaction, the BB interaction,
and the AB interaction.
So if you do just a
pairwise energy expression--
and should try this one,
it's very pedagogical--
and the atoms don't relax
away from the lattice,
then you'll find exactly that
these are pair energies, pair
potentials.
Now as soon as you let the atoms
relax away from the lattice
point, like maybe the a one
is bigger than the b one,
even in a pairwise energy
Hamiltonian these will not be
the pair interactions because
you cannot remove from these
energies.
You cannot cancel the energetic
effects between a and the rest
of the material and b and
the rest of the material, OK?
So the really cool thing about
these expansion coefficients
is that they will include
all that extra physics,
like relaxation away from
the equilibrium lattice site,
and I'll come back
to that later.
Come on.
Shouldn't write so much.
I think class is over, no?
Ah, there we go.
So I'll go back and forth
between writing the cluster
expansion in terms of the phi
alpha, so the basis function,
or being more
explicit and writing
the basic functions out as the
products of spins right away.
So all your physics
of your system,
all the energetics sits in
those coefficients v of course.
So the question is,
how do you get them?
Well, there's a lot
of different ways
that people have
tried to get them
and it depends a little
bit on the problem.
For simple Hamiltonians,
you can often really
just calculate them directly
by their definition,
essentially as the
projection of the energy
onto that basis function.
You can do that for
pairwise Hamiltonians even
including forced relaxation.
So even when atoms
don't sit on a lattice,
you can do it by
Fourier transforming,
and that's in one of the
reference that I give you.
But as soon as your
physics is very multibody,
it becomes very hard
to do it analytically.
There are people who do
it numerically very much
according to the definition.
So you literally take a
system and put an AA atom here
and then calculate a lot
of different configurations
around that.
And so literally start to
approximate those averages,
EAA average, EBB average.
The practical way that people
pretty much do it now most
of the time, which is also
the least elegant way,
is that essentially, you fit
your whole expansion at once
to a large number of
energy calculations.
So the first thing you
have to do, of course,
is to truncate your
Hamiltonian because this
is an infinite expansion.
You should really see this,
this is a trivial expansion.
You're expending 2 to
the n quantities and 2
to the n basis function, OK?
So it's only practical
if you truncate it,
but once you truncate you have
a finite set of coefficients
to determine.
So what you can do is literally
calculate the Hamiltonian,
or in this case, the energy for
a lot of these configurations.
Let's say there's 20 of these
v's you have to determine, then
essentially if you
have the energy at 20
different configurations you
could determine the interaction
coefficients.
Typically people use very
over-determined sets.
So if you want 20 of these,
you may do 50 of 50 energies
and do a squares
fitting just to make
the determination of
interactions much more stable.
So that's essentially
how it's done.
You have an energy method.
I wrote it as a first
principles method
here, could be
any energy method.
You calculate a lot of energies
of different configurations
and then you fit the Hamiltonian
and you plot the interactions
out.
It's really that simple.
And once you have your
lattice model Hamiltonian,
you now know that it's fairly
easy to equilibrate that.
So you can get ground
states out of that,
you can do a Monte
Carlo simulation on it
just like you're
doing in the lab,
and then get phase diagrams
thermodynamic properties out.
So essentially you can get
both the structures and all
the thermodynamic information
and more important,
as I'll show you
in a second, all
the information
you can derive from
the thermodynamic information,
which is something people
often forget.
So what I was going
to do is show you
a few examples of how this
is used and then in the end,
essentially come back to
some of the theory of that.
So here's one that shows
how elegant it can be.
What I'm going to show
you is a calculation
to try to get the solid
part of the calcium oxide,
magnesium oxide phase diagram.
This is perfect for
a cluster expansion.
Calcium oxide and
magnesium oxide
are both rock salt structures.
So a rock salt is
essentially an FCC lattice
of oxygens, which I think are in
this picture, the purple ones.
And then the cations,
either calcium or magnesium,
sit in the octahedral sites,
octahedral interstitials.
And the octahedral
interstitials of an FCC lattice
also form an FCC lattice.
So you can think of rock salts
as two interpenetrating FCC
lattices, one of
cations, one of anions.
So when you mix the
two, you're essentially
asking the question,
at each interstitial
is there a calcium or a
magnesium sitting there?
So again, you have a
perfect binary problem.
It's a lattice model.
But this already illustrates
a nice thing of this approach,
in your whole lattice model,
the oxygens won't appear.
So the variables
you use are only
going to be defined on
the cation lattices.
So the cations are
the smaller ones.
So on this one, you'll
have sigma i say plus 1
and on this one, you'll
have sigma j equals minus 1.
So you're essentially going
to express the energy solely
in terms of spin variables
on the cation sites,
and that makes sense.
There's nothing unknown
about the anion sites.
They're always
fully occupied, OK?
So the anions will show
up when you calculate
the energies of these
configurations, of course,
but there's really no
need to expend the energy
in their occupation variables
because they're always there.
They're always minus 1.
So you see, we're
going to end up
with an effective Hamiltonian
between the cations that
includes the energetic
intermediary of the anions
without explicitly
including them.
So how do you do
something like that?
Well, you truncate your
Hamiltonian [? number, ?]
it's always going to
be the same procedure.
You calculate the energy, a lot
of different configurations.
This is old work, so it wasn't
fully quantum mechanical.
There are two sets of points--
so this is actually energy--
I'm sorry, this is in
electron volt per cation.
The blue points are done
with empirical potentials.
Remember, we did that all the
way in the beginning of class?
These are essentially
Buckingham potentials
with electrostatics and shell
models attached to them.
And the open red circles
is a self-consistent PIB,
which is a really poor
man's quantum mechanics.
It's a sort of intermediate
between Thomas Fermi theory
and better quantum
mechanics, but think of it
as a poor man's
quantum mechanics,
and these are mixing energies.
So they're referenced to
0 here and here, that's
why they have that parabolic
shape because you force them
to 0 at 0 and 1.
First of all,
they're positive so
that means the two
things don't want
to mix, which is in accordance
to the phase diagram,
but you may notice
something already
that's kind of interesting.
The quantum mechanical
values actually
tend to be lower than
the potential ones,
and this is very common.
Typically a better
energy model will
lower the energy of
low symmetry states
more than a bad energy model.
And the reason is that usually
a good energy model has
more degrees of freedom, OK?
If you think of your potential
model has no electrons in it.
There can be no
electronic relaxation
by definition in a model
with empirical potentials
because you don't
have electrons.
A quantum mechanical
model has electrons in it
so you have more ways
for the system to relax.
And the lower the
symmetry, the more a system
can actually use those methods.
If your system is fully
constrained by symmetry,
then there's barely any
way the system can relax.
OK?
So this is something
you very typically see.
If you have energy methods
that are fitted to perfect bulk
properties, so they're fitted
in high symmetry environments,
if you then use them
on defect properties,
the better the
physics of the model
or the more degrees
of freedom usually
the lower the defect
energy will be.
But anyway, so you use this.
You'd fit your Hamiltonians
to it, your cluster expansion
to it, and you'd get a
bunch of pair interactions.
So the first six are
pair interactions.
Again, blue-- oh, dear.
Changed the color scheme here.
Blue is the quantum mechanics,
now the open circles
are the potentials,
and then there
are some triplets
interactions and
some quadruplets interactions.
And notice that the first
pair interaction is negative,
so what does that mean?
That means the nearest
neighbor's spin product
wants to be positive,
get your energy down.
So that means like things
want to be together.
Plus ones want to
be with plus ones,
minus ones want to
be with minus ones,
so that's phase separation.
You can already see it
from the interaction,
but notice the scale
of the interaction.
So this is now about 40 milli
electron volt per cation.
So this is a far cry.
This is much lower than
any direct electrostatic
interaction or even any direct
evaluation of a Buckingham
potential because you have
effective interactions.
Actually, if you think
of the definition
of the effective pair
interaction in this case--
so let me write it out.
So Vij would be 1/4.
Let me actually put calcium
and magnesium on here.
So it would be E magnesium,
magnesium averaged plus E
calcium, calcium minus 2e
calcium, magnesium on the i,
j sites.
So you should think about where
that effective interaction
comes from because look
at the electrostatics.
Does the electrostatics
contribute?
Magnesium and calcium
are both 2 plus.
Essentially if you froze those
two on their lattice sites,
you'd have in the first term 2
plus 2 plus plus the 2 plus 2
plus minus 2 times
the 2 plus 2 plus.
So the electrostatics
completely vanishes
from the effective
cluster interaction.
So it's interesting,
the fact that you
do this projection essentially
filters out the largest
part of the energy
here in the system,
but because it's the same
for both magnesium, magnesium
and calcium, calcium and
magnesium, calcium interactions
it's irrelevant for the
configurational thermodynamics
and the projection
essentially filters that out.
So where does the
remaining Vij come from?
Where does the
balance come from?
If you remember what we taught
you empirical potentials,
the way you set up an empirical
potential model for rock sites
is that you usually have, of
course, the electrostatics,
then you usually have an
oxygen, oxygen potential--
because the oxygen is the
biggest ion, they touch--
and then you have a
cation, oxygen potential.
Rarely do you have a
cation, cation potential.
So there's not even a direct
potential between the two.
So if you actually froze these
things on their lattice site,
that Vij is 0 because we just
said that the electrostatics
disappears.
There is no direct
cation, cation term,
so Vij is 0 in the case.
So I sort of give
the answer away
and I said if you freeze these
things on their lattice site,
where does the
interaction come from?
Well, if you freeze them,
there's no interaction.
So all the interaction
comes from relaxation.
OK?
The interaction
comes from the fact
that calcium is
bigger than magnesium
and so that sets up an
effective interaction.
So it's kind of cool because
with these interactions
you have a Hamiltonian
and a lattice model,
which people always
tend to associate
with frozen positions, but the
interaction comes essentially
from the positions
not being frozen,
from the fact that the bigger
atom pushes the smaller
one away.
OK?
And so this is
maybe the key point
to remember that once you
parameterize your Hamiltonian
with relaxed calculations,
that Ising model represents
the energy of those
relaxed configuration.
Not the ones where you're
frozen at lattice sites.
So when you do
hydrogen on palladium,
a lot of that interaction
that you get between hydrogen
on one spot on the
surface and the other one
has nothing to do with
hydrogen, hydrogen interaction.
It's actually all has to do with
relaxation of the surface sites
around the hydrogen.
You put a hydrogen here, the
palladium around it relaxes.
That's how it sees the
other hydrogen, not because
of a direct interaction.
And with hydrogen
that's not so dramatic.
If you that with other
absorbents like oxygen,
it's very dramatic.
They largely interact through a
strain induced in the surface.
OK.
So then you do Monte Carlo,
and here's the phase diagram.
It's a bit too many
things on this slide,
but essentially this is the
line you should be looking at.
This is the one with
potentials, so these
are the solubility limits
at low temperature.
So it's a two phase
region in between,
but you have some solubility of
MgO and CaO and of CaO and MgO,
and this is the
quantum mechanical one.
So of course this
becomes a miscibility gap
because there's no
liquid in the calculation
so if you somehow could include
the free energy of the liquid
it would cut off
that miscibility gap
and form a [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
But because you
don't have a liquid,
you're essentially looking at
only solid state transitions.
And again, you see
the same thing.
The quantum mechanics gives you
a higher solubility limit, so
a lower temperature which
you can get full solution.
Because it's sometimes
easier it can deal better
with the lower symmetry state.
OK.
So this is the
classic technique now
to deal with any substitutional
problem and I would say almost
any crystalline problem
because even if you
work on systems where
there are multiple lattice
types in play--
I mean, if you think of
simple metals you could think,
well, maybe there's
some that ordered
on a BCC lattice and some
that order on FCC lattice,
you can cluster expend
them separately and obtain
free energies from Monte Carlo
and then put them together.
That's why this is essentially
the method by which
any multicomponent crystalline
problem is equilibrated,
but I'll show you
some of the older work
just because historically
it's kind of cool.
This is the lithium
aluminum system,
which was I think only the
second or third system that
was done at [INAUDIBLE]
by this method.
This was done in the early '80s.
So the reason they did
this in the early '80s
because everybody thought we
were going to make airplanes
out of lithium aluminum
because lithium
is the lightest solid element
in the periodic table.
So any lithium you
can put in an alloy
makes it really
considerably lighter,
and the interesting piece
occurs here, which you can see.
There's a delta phase
here, which is metastable,
sits about here.
And what typically people
do is they solution
to heat up high temperature then
[? quench ?] down so that you
precipitate out delta phase
to strengthen the alloy.
It's difficult to
do experimentally
because this is a
metastable phase,
so it's a little
hard to study it.
But of course computationally,
all metastability means
is that there's something else
that's more stable, so as soon
as you remove that from the
picture and the simulation
you can stabilize it.
And so this was one of those
early calculations where
they did exactly
what we showed here,
build a cluster
expansion, parameterize
it, [INAUDIBLE]
functional theory.
In this case, did Monte Carlo
do the statistical mechanics
to find temperature
and essentially get
this calculated phase diagram?
And this is the
equilibrium phase diagram,
but then you can also
do the metastable.
This is the delta phase
precipitated by essentially
removing the free energy
curves of the stable phases
and look at them.
The liquid was kind of
empirically added, I think,
to this calculation.
This was my own PhD thesis,
so I have to show it.
Most of my PhD thesis
were just what is 1,
2, 3, 4, lines, so
I got off easily.
But this is the phasing
[INAUDIBLE] copper oxide,
which probably most
of you familiar
is a fairly well known high
temperature superconductor.
And the critical issue, or
one of the critical issues
was, how the material behaves
as a function of oxygen content.
Essentially that z
up in the formula
can go anywhere from 6 to 7 and
at 7 it's a high temperature
superconductor,
at 6 and 1/2 it's
a low temperature
superconductor,
and at 6 it's an
anti ferromagnet.
And so figuring out what the
phase ion looked like was,
I guess, worth the PhD thesis.
And essentially it's, again,
a lattice model problem.
You have a bunch of sites
where the oxygen can sit.
When you start
taking out the oxygen
it's now the site can be
vacant or filled with oxygen.
So it's a binary problem.
So you cluster expended
the same thing.
In those days, the quantum
mechanics wasn't all that good
and you did Monte Carlo and
you get a phase diagram.
And what's neat about this O2,
to my knowledge, this phase--
I think there's just
some history with it--
was probably the
first structure I
think that ever was predicted
with quantum mechanics
before it was seen
experimentally.
Now there have been a
lot of cases of that,
but this was actually
in the late '80s,
and it may have been
the first case where
the experimental
evidence came afterwards.
OK.
Here's a lot more
complicated systems,
so this is the
lithium cobalt oxide
I showed you in the beginning.
There's cobalt layers,
there's oxygen layers,
but the key component
is the lithium layer.
As you take lithium out you
have a vacancy lithium problem.
So again, you
expend in variables
that only describe the
occupation on this layer, OK?
So you don't really have
to deal with the cobalt,
with the oxygen, you
just deal with that
when you do the
energy calculations
and you get a bunch of
effective interactions.
And again, let me stress
that these ECI are
effective interactions.
If you look at the
first neighbor,
it's only 30 milli
electron volt, OK?
To give you an idea, those
first neighbor distances
in the lithium plane
are about 3 Angstrom.
If you evaluated the
electrostatic source of a plus
1 charge and a plus 1
charge over 3 Angstrom,
you'd get something that's
close to an electron volt. OK?
But you see, because
you're taking
effective interactions
you essentially
remove most of that.
Well, first some
of it is screened--
because you're not in a vacuum
doing your electrostatic,
some of it is screened
by the oxygens that
are close by-- but
you're also canceling
a lot of energetic
effects and really seeing
the only part that's relevant
for the thermodynamics.
And then you can,
again, do Monte Carlo
just like we've done in the
lab, get a phase diagram.
This is the kind
of phase diagram
that you would not get out
of straight Monte Carlo.
The hydrogen and palladium
problem we gave you,
you can do that
literally by looking
at the output of
the Monte Carlo,
by looking at the heat
capacity, looking at the energy,
because the system
equilibrates very well.
When it doesn't
equilibrate you really
have to do free
energy integrations
and look at where
they intersect.
This space also was predicted
three years before it
was seen experimentally, so
this approach has a really very
powerful predictive
capability because you control
almost all the approximations.
So essentially, you have to
live with the approximations
in density functional theory.
So whatever the accuracy of
your electronic Hamiltonian,
you can't do any better.
OK?
But from there, you control
all the approximations.
So if you don't like the
convergence of your cluster
expansion, well, you
add more terms to it.
OK?
So essentially you can make
as accurate a representation
of your quantum
mechanics as you want.
And that's why you
can make Hamiltonians
that are very accurate, but
they live on a lattice model
so they're extremely
fast to search.
I mean, you've done the
hydrogen on palladium.
Hydrogen on palladium, that
trivial job [INAUDIBLE],,
this 4, 5 million spin flips
per second on a stupid, old IBM
computer.
So on a new machine,
you can run 10,
15 million spin
flips per second,
so you can search configuration
space extremely fast.
OK?
And so that's why it's so good
at finding new structures.
OK, I was going to show
you a surface problem.
So here's platinum 111.
Reason I took
platinum, it's sort
of an important material for
all kinds of catalysts and so.
And every time you have
these FCC surfaces,
the possible absorption
sites essentially
form a triangular lattice.
I should go to a
different color here.
So you have these really old
form of triangular lattice.
There we go.
Triangular lattice.
So if you want to study
the absorption of something
like hydrogen or oxygen, again,
you build a lattice model.
Then you have to do density
functional theory calculations
to parameterize it
and I think you've
done that now in the lab.
So because this is surface you
would set up a slab geometry.
So you essentially would
take a few layers of platinum
and then put stuff on
the surface to absorb it,
and you arrange a vacuum above
it and do the DFT calculations.
OK.
So here's that
result. Again, this
shows both LD [? and GGA ?]
but again, we plot them--
this is oxygen absorbed
on platinum 111.
We reference the full coverage
and the zero coverage to 0.
You may be a little
surprised that you
can set two points to
0 on the energy scale,
but one, of course, is obvious.
So you can always reference
one point to 0 on energy scale.
The reason you can
set the second one
to 0, what you're
essentially doing
is setting it 0 for
the chemical potential
because the chemical
potential is, in some sense,
the slope of that curve.
It's the energy changed just
by adding oxygen in this case.
So you're essentially
referencing
the chemical potential to 0
by setting two points to 0.
So you do that, same thing.
You fit interactions.
I've actually made some
copies of real notes
so you see how this
is really done.
So people sketching out
on triangle lattice,
different interactions.
You find their value,
again, they're very small.
The black points is
for oxygen or platinum,
the other one is on ruthenium.
You know it's about 75 for
a near neighbor interaction
and then it decays
very quickly very fast.
And you know that they actually
have to be in that range
because if you're going to see
phase transitions in the range
of, say, 0 to 1,000
Kelvin, your energies have
to live on that energy scale
and 1,000 Kelvin is what?
About 100,000--
well, 1,000 Celsius
is about 100 milli electron
volt so your interactions
have to be in that range
for stuff to happen.
So I thought I'd show you,
rather than a nice picture
of a phasing-- hold on.
So how would you look
for phase transitions?
You do the same stuff
you do in the lab,
you track heat capacities,
you track energies.
So this is for the same run,
different oxygen chemical
potentials.
So with your experience, what's
happening here at about 940k?
This clearly looks like
a phase transition,
first or second order.
What's your guess?
Second?
It's hard to say, but it
looks like second order.
I mean, it's maybe not
refined enough to look,
but there's clearly a
peak in the heat capacity.
Let's say we take, I don't
know, the green curve,
which is at the
particular oxygen there's
a peak in the heat capacity.
It's not very well defined, you
shouldn't let yourself mislead.
If you didn't draw the lines
here but just the points,
that peak is essentially
defined by one point.
I mean, you should
always be careful.
You may have very
spurious behavior going on
in one similar Monte
Carlo solution.
The other peaks have
slightly more points,
but normally if
you really wanted
to know which is
first or second order
you would refine it a lot more
near the phase transition.
Again, the energy
seems to be continuous,
but don't let the
lines fool you.
You've taken, say, this
point and that point
and connected them, so of
course they're continuous,
but maybe what this thing does
is it continues and then shoots
down to the other vertically, so
it could still be first order.
So you would normally
refine this a lot more.
And the other
thing, if you really
want to know that
something's second order,
you look at the scaling of the
heat capacity with system size
and that's the
really accurate way
to know that something's
second order.
You're normalized heat capacity
in a second order transition,
so the heat capacity
per side scales
like the square root of the
number of lattice sites, OK?
You'll find that already
in your simple example,
your simple homework problem
of hydrogen on palladium,
you'll find it remarkably hard
to identify in certain regions
whether the phase transition
is first or second order.
That's why you put
them in, they are
are both first and second order.
So [INAUDIBLE]
beautiful phasing,
I thought I'd show you
guys how it's really done.
When we do Monte Carlo, this is
really like a puzzle, you know?
In papers we always show
these nicely drawn things,
but this is how you get to it.
You do an enormous
amount of scans in mu.
So you scan this way, then
you scan in temperature,
and you slowly start
piecing together
which phases exist where,
where they disappear,
how they disappear, first
or second order reactions.
So this is one that is near
completion with a few question
marks whether these are
like first or second order.
And then later you
draw nice lines,
but this is one of the
problems with Monte Carlo
because it's a
stochastic method.
It really is a lot
a lot of puzzling.
And what you'll find is
that the last thing that's
useful, the least
useful thing is actually
looking at the spins.
That's people's first intuition.
I'm going to actually look at
the configuration in my system.
You know, any time systems
are partially disordered,
just looking at them is
the best way to fool you.
If you look at something
partially disordered,
half of the class will say it's
ordered and half of the class
will say it's disordered,
and it's really
the thermodynamic behavior
that tells you in which phase
it still is.
If it's in an ordered state,
so in a compound state,
that means that you
should be able to push it
to a disordered state.
OK?
That means you should see
somewhere a phase transition
as you raise the temperature
or drive the chemical potential
to another phase.
If it's already disordered,
if you heat it further up
it won't go to a phase
transition anymore.
OK.
Just to show you that you
can push this a lot harder
and make it a lot
more complicated.
I'll show you something that
gets a little more abstract,
and it's from a problem that
I worked on quite recently.
It's absorption
induced segregation,
and here's the problem.
So the problem before was
oxygen absorbing on platinum,
but if you have actually
a platinum metal
alloy like a platinum metal
catalyst, in this case,
platinum ruthenium,
then you have
two configurational problems.
So the first question is,
what's on the surface?
Is it oxygen or vacancy?
Is the site oxygen or vacancy?
But there's also segregation
thermodynamics now.
On the surface, you now
may not have pure platinum,
you may have either platinum or
ruthenium and the two interact.
What segregates to the surface
is influenced by what absorbs.
You see, you may think of
that as a quaternary problem
because essentially,
what's in play now?
Platinum is in play, ruthenium
is in play, oxygen's in play,
and vacancies are in play--
vacancies being vacant
absorption sites.
But it's actually
a 2 plus 2 problem.
It's really a binary
configuration problem
in the surface layer and
then a binary configuration
problem on top of
the surface layer,
and so you can still
perfectly solve
this with a binary
cluster expansion.
It's just that your spin
means something different
whether you're in
the surface layer
or whether you're in
the absorbent layer.
So you could call
them different,
but you don't have to.
You could say, well, there
are variables that is,
say, this describes what's
in the absorption layer
and I could just call a
new set of variables delta,
this describes within
the surface layer,
and then I could
literally expend
in the products of these.
But to be honest, you could
just all call them sigmas.
OK.
They just mean
something different
whether they're defined on
this site or on that site, OK?
And so you can do
the same technique
and now essentially expend
a quaternary problem.
And you do the same whole
thing, you calculate
a lot of configurations.
Because your configuration
space is essentially bigger,
you'll need more information
to parameterize it.
And then you do Monte
Carlo and equilibrate it
and here's an example.
This is, at a given temperature,
driving up the oxygen chemical
potential so we expect
more oxygen to absorb,
and that's what you see.
But you can actually track the
amount of ruthenium segregating
to the surface and as you bring
more oxygen to the surface,
you actually start increasing
the amount of ruthenium
in the surface as well.
And so you can really
solve the thermodynamics
of these problems by
[INAUDIBLE] initial methods
by going through this
cluster expansion,
but you can actually
look at the sites.
Orange is the platinum surface,
red is the oxygen absorbed,
and this picture
here is the same
with the oxygen stripped off so
you see underlying ruthenium.
So as you increase
the oxidation,
you essentially
get more ruthenium
to the surface and
more oxidation.
This is sort of more and
more, higher and higher
oxygen pressure.
OK.
Let me show you one more
quickly before I continue
the theory and the
reason I want to show you
this is because it's sort
of a little different.
This is a structural
problem from hydrogen
modified aluminum fracture.
OK.
The problem there is that
impurity embrittlement
in metals is a big issue.
There's a lot of metals whose
ductile behavior becomes very
poor when there's
impurity present,
and hydrogen embrittlement
in particular is a bad one.
And it's not that
hydrogen's so much
worse than other impurities
but first of all,
hydrogen tends to be a common
impurity because it's available
everywhere.
Any time you have corrosion
reactions going on,
you often produce hydrogen.
Any time you're working
in acid environments,
you produce hydrogen, and it
tends to be a fast diffuser.
So there's a lot of
other impurities,
but a lot of other
impurities sort of never
make it to the problem
areas in the material
but hydrogen tends
to be a fast diffuser
So the way people have dealt
with this in quantum mechanics
is literally by looking at
how planes decohere here
with and without hydrogen.
And of course, if you
hydrogen in between it,
it decoheres more easily.
There's less work of decohesion.
But if you want to look at
the structural problem of what
happens when you do
this with hydrogen,
if you want to
equilibrate the hydrogen
it becomes a lot harder.
So let me sort of
first tell you how
would you do this
without hydrogen.
You could make a slab, you
would define a plane where
you open up the slab
and you remove the two
slabs farther and
farther apart so it's
like you're opening a crack.
You keep track of the energy
and the derivative of that is,
of course, the force required
to separate the slab.
But think of the
problem now if you want
to do that with an impurity.
You have to now equilibrate the
impurity at every separation
of the slab.
OK?
So you pull the crack open
a little more, you now
have to figure out what
happens to that impurity
there because as that
impurity equilibrates,
not only its structure
equilibrates by the way,
but also its composition because
segregation to those surfaces
is an open system problem.
The concentration
there is not fixed
because it comes from the
bulk or from a gas phase.
So it's actually a
grand canonical problem,
it's a constant chemical
potential problem rather than
a constant composition problem.
So you see that the
hard problem you have.
Not only do you have to
arrange the impurities
in the most stable
way because that's
going to determine the energy
and therefore the force
it requires to open
up those planes,
but you also need to equilibrate
the amount of impurity
in that crack.
And so this is actually why it's
so hard to include chemistry
in mechanical calculations,
because you're really
working on two different
time scales that
are very hard to combine.
And so the solution
here was essentially
to calculate the relevant
free energy of hydrogen
for any state of crack opening,
for any state of separation
of the planes you tried to
get the equilibrium hydrogen
content by a cluster
expansion and then
from that envelope of free
energies you get the force.
So it's again, the same thing.
You define a lattice model.
This was hydrogen on one
side of the crack opening,
hydrogen sites on another
side of the crack opening.
So now you have interactions
within one plane,
but also between the two.
You do a bunch of first
principles computations,
so it's, again, the same thing
to fit those interactions.
Then you're going
to do Monte Carlo.
You're going to, in this
case, get your free energies
in the derivatives of the
free energy with respect
to the separation is
going to be the force.
So in this case,
this is the force
as a function of slab
separation for all
the different
hydrogen coverages.
So I plotted the force.
I really should have plotted
the energy because the energy is
the quantity that's expended.
And then you get interactions.
In this case, I'm
only showing two.
So there's an in-plane
hydrogen interaction,
that's the red one here,
and there's an inter-plane.
The inter-plane is between
the two openings of the crack
and of course, that
one tends to go to 0
as you separate more and more.
OK?
So now the cool thing is
at every state of the crack
opening, you can actually get
the free energy of the system
fully equilibrated.
And so if you get
the free energy,
you can actually find
the force, and this
is the fully equilibrated
thermodynamic trajectory,
that red line.
And what's really surprising
is that because you fully
equilibrate the
system, it suddenly
looks very different from
what you thought it would be
and what you would
have gotten in
an unequilibrated calculation.
These black lines,
this is what you
got in an unequilibrated
calculation.
It sort of makes
sense, you know?
As you pull, the force goes up.
No surprise, I mean.
And then you reach
a critical point,
a point of maximum force.
At that point, you're unstable
because essentially the force,
as you pull further, goes
down so you're unstable.
On the downslope you're
essentially unstable.
But look at the red line.
So this as a chemically
equilibrated system
behaves very different.
Essentially you
pull a little bit,
you open the crack a
little bit, and then
the crack opens with
no increase in force.
OK?
And then you pull the
saturated crack apart.
And essentially what this
is is, because you've
done your thermodynamics
right, you actually
have a first order
transition in length space.
OK, this is a length
discontinuity.
It's just like a
volume discontinuity
in a regular first
order transition, OK?
Here, essentially the crack is
separating at constant force.
OK?
It's like when you do a
first order transition.
Upon heating, you're
putting an entropy
at constant temperature
for example,
or if you do a pressure
induced phase transition,
you get a volume change
at constant pressure.
OK?
So it's the same thing.
But you see that by
doing the chemistry
right and the equilibration,
you get very different results.
OK.
So the last thing I want to
do is come back to the idea
that we started with
and I wrote down
the energy as a function
of configuration
and and then showed you
how you cluster expended.
What I want to do is
now come back again
to what the definition
should be of that energy,
and we did that at the back
end of the Monte Carlo lecture
but because it's
kind of important
I want to come back to it
because it's not totally clear
what that energy or that
Hamiltonian in the lattice
model should be.
So let me take a step back--
and I know you've seen this,
but I'm going to go through it.
If you want to get the
free energy of a system
you normally want to include all
excitations because essentially
you have to calculate
the partition function,
you have to trace
over all excitations,
and that will give you the
full partition function
and the [INAUDIBLE] will
give you the free energy.
So if you think of
the most basic system,
we'll always have
vibrational excitations, OK?
If we have anything with a
binary problem like A's or B's
or something and
vacancies, we will
have configurational
excitations,
and then unless
you're in an insulator
you'll have electronic
excitations.
The idea we talked
about last time
is that the way you can
define a Hamiltonian that
lives in this space, which is
the one with the slower time
scale, is by integrating
over the faster timescale.
And I started to
show you last time
I think when we finished
the Monte Carlo lecture.
And let me sort of go through
that formal description
again so we see exactly what
our latest model Hamiltonian is.
So I'm going to do it
here only with vibrations
of the fast time scale
and substitutions
as the slow timescale,
and after you'll
see how it would go with
electronic excitations as well.
So I replace the coordinate ri,
so this is a set of coordinates
that describe the atom,
into a lattice site
position and a deviation
from that lattice site.
OK?
The lattice site
position, that is fully
defined by the set of
configurational variable,
sigma, and the deviation from
the ideal lattice site position
are called configuration nu.
So the combination
of sigma and nu
is really the same as the
set of vectors ri, OK?
So what I'm going to do is--
you already see where I'm
going probably with this.
I'm going to trace
over the nus to get
a Hamiltonian in the sigmas.
OK.
So the full
partition function is
the sum of the exponential
of the energy, which
depends both on
sigma and nu, and I
sum over the sigma
states and the nu states.
OK?
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to do the inner sum
so that I'm only left with
the sum over sigmas of sum
f, which is the Hamiltonian
in the configurational space.
And if you look to make
these to the same, what
that f should be?
Well, f is the free energy that
I get by tracing over the nus.
OK.
I mean, there's no physics here.
This is pure and simple
substitution of variables.
So I call, essentially,
this sum here
is the exponential
of minus beta f,
which means that f is the
log of that exponential.
So look at what I
formally end up with.
I have a partition
function that only sums
over substitutional states.
So this is a problem that lives
in the same space as a lattice
model because I'm only coming
over discrete configurational
states.
So what I'm really saying is
that if I do this partition
function correctly, I have
the full partition function
and therefore, the free energy.
But to do it correctly, my
Hamiltonian in my lattice model
state needs to be f, not e.
And what is that f?
Well, f is essentially
a free energy.
It's the log of a
partition function.
And what partition
function is it?
It's the partition
function by summing over
all the faster states.
So the problem is,
essentially, simple.
The Hamiltonian you should use
in your slow time scale space
is the one you
get by integrating
or by calculating the free
energy of your fast time
scales.
So in this case,
what should you do?
In everything I showed
you earlier this morning,
I used the energy
as the Hamiltonian.
OK?
I use the direct to DFT
energy in my Hamiltonian.
What I really should have used
is the vibrational free energy
to be correct.
If I use the vibrational free
energy in that Hamiltonian,
I would have gotten the
full partition function
and therefore, I would have
gotten the total free energy
of the system.
So what did I do instead?
I didn't calculate this.
I approximated
this by something.
I approximated this by
the state in this ensemble
with the lowest energy.
I mean, if you think of
this as a free energy,
this is going to be a free
energy plus some entropy term,
which you could think
of as a ground state
energy plus contributions
from excited states.
OK?
I've basically said, I'm taking
this just as the ground state
energy in this
[? ensemble ?] because I'm
taking the lowest energy
configuration that I
can get by varying over this.
OK?
And what is varying over this?
What are the nus?
The nus are the displacement
from the lattice sites.
So essentially I'm
relaxing my system,
letting it displace
from the lattice site,
I get the lowest energy
state in the ensemble,
and that's what I expend.
So when I'm done,
what do I have?
When I'm done and I do Monte
Carlo with that Hamiltonian,
I have essentially
the right energetics,
I have configuration
entropy, but I
don't have vibrational entropy.
To have vibrational entropy,
I would have to do this sum,
not just take the
lowest energy term.
OK.
Come on.
OK, let me sort of skip that.
OK.
People actually
have done examples
where they do the
full integration
over vibrational states
rather than just approximating
that ensemble with its
lowest energy term.
You see that it's
a lot more work.
Remember that to parameterize
the cluster expansion,
I need the Hamiltonian evaluated
for a bunch of configurations.
Even in the simplest case that's
easily 40, 50 configurations.
So if you want to
include the vibrations,
you actually have to do, for 50
configurations, the full phonon
DOS or do molecular dynamics on
them and integrate the phonon
and get the vibrational
free energy through that.
So it's like two orders
of magnitude more work.
So rather than just
the energy, you
want to get the whole
vibrational spectrum,
and that's why people
usually don't do it.
But the nice thing is
that in this approach,
you can do it if
you really want to.
And I'll show you one example
where people did it and looked
at the difference.
It was the very simple case
of the cadmium magnesium phase
diagram.
It was done by Mark Asta,
who's now at Northwestern.
So this is the experimental
phase diagram actually.
So this is the calculation
with no vibrational entropy
and with vibrational entropy.
So the first one is
the one that I sort of
showed you as the standard one.
You just take the lowest
energy for a lattice model
configuration and you do
Monte Carlo then with that.
And this is if you literally
do the whole phonon
DOS for every configuration.
And what you see is that there
is some change in topology.
I mean, look at this point
has come down considerably
and even has changed
the topology somewhat,
and usually that's what you see.
You rarely see new phases
new ground states come
in when you include
vibrations, but you
will change the topology of
phase diagrams, for example.
There are a few known cases.
Usually people write a
physical review letter
whenever they find
one where phrases
come in purely stabilized by
their vibrational entropy.
It's a bit of a
puzzle, actually, why
it doesn't happen more because
the vibrational entropy is
large.
It's essentially 3r.
Remember the law
of the [INAUDIBLE]??
The entropy is 3rt.
The [INAUDIBLE] is 3r,
so the entropy is 3rt.
The configurational entropy at
its maximum is only r log 2.
At 50-50, in a binary alloy,
you have the maximum entropy
and it's actually
the logarithm of 1/2,
so it's minus the
logarithm of 2.
So you either have--
that's about, what, 0.67?
So the configurational
entropy only about 0.67r,
the vibration one is 3r,
so it's a lot bigger.
But of course, what
matters is the difference
in that quality between
different structures
and different states.
And even though the
configurational entropy
is the smaller one, it
tends to be the one that's
more different between different
states than the vibration one,
and that's why we
sort of all hope
that it's OK to often leave
the vibrational entropy out
because often most
of it tends to cancel
between different states.
OK.
So sometime in 1994, somebody
compiled all the systems
done with these methods.
This was 1994.
We stopped compiling after '94
because that was just way too
many studies going on,
but this kind of approach
has now been used for
the study hundreds
and hundreds of
[INAUDIBLE] structure
and thermodynamics problems.
People do higher
component now, ternary's
it's still a lot more work.
This is a simple ternary.
And then I gave you a
series of references.
I wanted to show you some of
the older work, that's actually
the last references here.
Often the older work, even
though it's not up to date,
but it's also not confused
by a lot of complications
so it's often very easy to
read, very elegant to read.
But the key review
paper is essentially
this one, which is like
150 pages or something
like that which contains the
ideas of the cluster expansion
and a lot more.
And then my own work is just a
short review on how that works,
how you apply the [INAUDIBLE]
sites, and the one by Alexander
Zunger is essentially
the same thing
but how you apply that
in semiconductors.
And the fourth one is
the most recent one,
which my own grad student
wrote, Axel Van de Walle,
because he's been
kind of instrumental.
He's gone to making this
into automated codes
and so on, has a whole
code suite and the paper
is about that, how
you train Monte Carlo
and so to automatically look
for phase transitions and things
like that.
OK.
I think that's it.
So let's see, what day's today?
Today's Thursday, so Tuesday
we'll meet again here.
I'll start talking about
accelerated molecular dynamics
and find another topic
to talk about as well,
and then Thursday
is Chris Wolverton.
So I'll see you,
have a good weekend.